je vous propose de sourire un instant
moment après cette actualité est un peu
pesante avec notre invité qui est
isabelle huppert que l'on peut voir sur
les écrans à l'heure actuelle dans la
femme de mon pote
le dernier film de bertrand blier avec
coluche et thierry lhermitte
on dit que c'est assez terrifiante par
vic bertrand blier terrifiant oh non non
non j'ai pas trouvé et pas trop
difficile non non non il est il est
charmant
alors qu'elle souhaitait le thème de ce
film maudit xv également que c'est un
petit peu les valseuses à l'envers oui
en place et les valseuses dans la mesure
où une fois de plus bertrand blier
traits d'un date rio comme il l'avait
déjà fait dans les valseuses dans la
préparez vos mouchoirs
et c'est une énième variation sur
l'éternel trio le mari la femme et
l'amant et c'est une réflexion un peu
douce amère comme ça sur les difficultés
des mets en amitié et en amour c'est un
peu de bigeon s'aimaient d'amour tendre
qui serait coluche et et thierry
lhermitte et puis une femme sur 20 et
les ennuis commencent
les annales va pas déflorer tout le film
et je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait de ce film donc dans lequel vous
apparaissez avec thierry lhermitte et
coluche
je te présente micky c'est quelqu'un qui
compte énormément dans ma vie allez
salut
tu pourrait m'expliquer ce que tu
fabriques danse plumard je me suis fais
draguer et ça t'arrive souvent oui
quand les mecs aux gens ouais eh ben dis
donc tu dois en connaître un rayon sur
la matelasserie française
il se fait ça tous copains je suis par
son copain je suis son ami j'ai même son
meilleur ami
nuance il prend aucune décision
importante sont consultés j'ai une
énorme influence sur lui ça fait dix ans
que c'est comme ça et personne n'a
réussi à nous éloigner un lot et miss
même une femme et des femmes y en a
elles pensent elles arrivent et
repartent et nous reste on bouge pas et
on les regarde s'éloigner alors de la
dentellière la femme fatale de la femme
de mon pote il ya tout un travail
oui à du temps qu'a passé lanaudière et
est loin mais comment travaille-t-on
avec coluche ou connu cela on ne
connaîtrait auparavant non je ne
connaissais pas du tout on va découvrir
un coluche très différents je crois
coluche était avant tout un personnage
de music hall qui qui s'abritait
derrière ses propres textes et puis là
on découvre un un acteur extraordinaire
un acteur moi il me faisait beaucoup
pensé à are et mieux quelquefois comme
ça il a une humanité une gravité les
drôles mais il est très très émouvant et
dans ce film il et il est assez
surprenant parce qu'il est d'une grande
sobriété ce dont on le croyait peut-être
pas capable et donc ça facilite les
rapports avec riz c'est pas coluche
touchant wista coluche très très
émouvant très touchant et très très
nouveau et
très inattendu isabelle huppert vos
projets mes projets pour l'instant je
n'en ai pas beaucoup apprécié on parle
donc pas non pas de pas de film précis
en prévision merci